à toulouse les ténors monsieur lui tout
seul un grand théâtre nous dit thorium
un zénith le musée d'art contemporain à
l'orée de l'an 2000 la ville se dote
d'équipements culturels à la hauteur de
ses ambitions
une entreprise vient facilement de la
région parisienne vers toulouse
parce que les gens savent que à toulouse
ils vont pas tomber dans un désert
culturel mais au contraire dans une
ville qui peut offrir une gamme
d'activités extrêmement diversifiée
fermé depuis près de cinq siècles
l'église saint pierre des cuisines
ouvrira ses portes au public le 8
novembre prochain
elle a été transformée en auditorium
pour le conservatoire national de région
et accueillera des concerts et des
spectacles de danse sous les 400 places
assises
la crypte a été préservée tout comme les
clous ou l'armée napoléonienne accrocher
les harnachements des chevaux qu'elle
héberge est au premier étage
l'église a retrouvé tout son volume et
même récupéré un mot du xiiie siècle qui
avait disparu on comprend les angoisses
de celui qu'il a bâti et qu'il a pensé à
l'origine
oui choses très émouvant parce que c'est
se remettre dans sa pensée
ici les 9000 places du zénith seront
exclusivement rock variété mais 120
décibels de nuisance sonore puisque les
zéniths obéissent à des normes
draconiennes en matière d'isolation
phonique d'acoustique et de sonorisation
vérification lors du premier concert
vers avril 99 puis ce sera au tour du
musée d'art contemporain d'ouvrir ses
portes en novembre 98
dans les locaux des anciens abattoirs
construit par une vitrine c'est que
démunis ce qui vaut bien une distorsion
linguistique
étant donné que notre logo et les
abattoirs
je crois qu'on ne peut pas donner rendez
vous aux abattoirs ce qui serait très
mal c'est en mai à les abattoirs
outre les collections permanentes de la
ligue 2 le samedi deux semaines
d'occupation cause des avoirs a tenu
jusqu'ici faute de place le musée
démarrent dans la vie avec un joli quel
doux il y aura ce dépôt magistrale que
nous octroie le musée national d'art
moderne
en l'occurrence la collection cordier
dont on avait vu des éléments jacobins
il ya je crois un an et demi c'est
l'état qui finance ce musée à 40% et
participe ainsi que la région et le
département aux autres chantiers
ce qui est bien ville à financer ces
grands travaux on réalise tout ceci qui
donne du travail à l'économie régionale
qui créent les emplois sans augmenter
l'emploi et la charge pour le contrer
dernier chantier culturel la médiathèque
de marengo dont les travaux vont
commencer ce trimestre et qui devrait
sortir de terre en 2000 juste pour le
troisième millénaire